the mob takes if it if you're innocent
why are you taking the Fifth Amendment
Fifth Amendment
horrible
for all of the reasons provided in my
answer which is Incorporated herein in
its entirety
I declined to answer the question
taking the Fifth Amendment it is a right
under the Constitution of the United
States against uh being forced to
self-incriminate it's not I don't want
to testify therefore I'm going to take
the Fifth Amendment it's not I'm tired
today therefore I'm pleading the Fifth
Amendment that's not what it exists for
it exists if you committed a crime you
cannot be compelled to testify against
yourself
so by him taking the fifth 400 times in
this case it means he believes
reasonably believes he could
self-incriminate by answering the
questions